hi I'm Jerry shadle from the departments
of pathology and genetics at Yale
University my colleagues and I have
completed a study described in our
article in cell that illuminates a new
pathway through which mitochondrial
stress leads to hearing loss in mice our
results shed significant new light into
maternally inherited deafness and
age-related hearing loss in humans as
well as the complex tissue specificity
of mitochondrial disease pathology
mitochondria are essential organelles in
your cells that are required for energy
production they also have DNA in that
you inherit from your mother there are
many mutations in mitochondrial DNA that
you if you inherit from your mother
cause specific human diseases the
specific mutation we studied in and our
investigations is one that causes
maternally inherited deafness and this
mutation occurs in these large
assemblies in mitochondria called
ribosomes and these ribosomes are
important for expressing the genes that
the mitochondrial DNA encodes
specifically the mutation is in the RNA
subunit of the ribosome and what we
found is that the mutation itself is not
what's causing the disease but rather
it's causing an increase in methylation
in the RNA near in a nearby site the
breakthrough was really our
understanding of the enzyme that does
that methylation when you overexpress
that enzyme in cells it causes the cells
to die by a process called apoptosis
what we found is that patient cell lines
that have the deafness mutation are also
hypermethylated and that they exhibit
the same a pop tonic or cell death
phenotype so that really led us to put
two and two together where we thought we
overexpressed this enzyme in mice we
would hyper methylate that molecule and
cause deafness modeling the human
disease a major outstanding question in
understanding mitochondrial pathology is
the often extreme tissue specificity of
the diseases that are associated with
mitochondrial dysfunction this is kind
of curious because mitochondria are
generally thought of as ubiquitous and
all of your cells so it's sort of not
straightforward to understand why types
of
lead to tissue specific affects the
deafness mutation is a hallmark case in
point is a specific point mutation the
only pathology you get is deafness what
we found is that the disease
mitochondria from patient cell lines
that produce these reactive oxygen free
radicals that activate a signaling
pathway that causes the cells to die and
if you in our mouse models where we show
that this pathway is active if you
deactivate that pathway we can actually
spare them from going deaf there are
several implications to our study first
we have elucidated an interesting
pathway by which mitochondrial oxygen
radicals are actually acting in a
signaling mode as opposed to a damaging
mode which is what they're usually
thought of in terms of disease in aging
second we have developed a really robust
mouse model to study mitochondrial
diseases and the tissue specificity that
they exhibit thirdly humans that have
this mutation can go deaf when they're
exposed to certain environmental toxins
for example aminoglycoside antibiotics
so this mouse model will also be
instrumental for trying to understand
the intersection between the environment
and genetics in this disease lastly the
pathology that we found in the mice
which is death of certain critical cells
in the inner ear are the same types of
pathology that we see in humans when
they lose their hearing normally as we
age so if this pathway that we have
found is the same pathway this is a new
potential way that we can
therapeutically intercede and maybe
prevent age-related hearing loss
you